alors c'est pas toujours été facile avec
dutronc et pourtant vous aviez eu les
plus grandes stars à vos pieds moi je
sais rien on m'attendait attendait brian
jones mick jagger bob dylan c'est vrai
quand même
françoise bob dylan c'est vrai mais il
paraît qu est ce qui est vrai gill and
the villa dans 64 on est on est né en 64
qu'est ce qui s'est passé le mieux mais
si je tenais à ce qui s'est passé
bob dylan en 64 tombe en arrêt devant
une photo de françoise hardy en
couverture de bugs fait par william
klein il veut en fait personne ne
connaissait de bob dylan à l'époque il
venait voir hugues aufray hugues aufray
voulait adapter les chansons de bienne
en france donc il a fait l'autre venait
le voir et deux ans plus tard il revient
il est dans sa loge à l'olympia il
refuse de monter sur scène tant qu'il
n'a pas vu françoise hardy quand même
c'est vrai ça ouais ouais gt gt
je les folles de baume de bob dylan
j'adorais ses chansons mon rêve c'était
de le voir sur scène il arrive à paris
pour chanter à ce moment là j'étais sur
un tournage grand prix avec yves montand
on était à monaco je suppliais john
frankenheimer de me laisser monter à
paris pour le concert de bob dylan et
comme il devait avoir des penchants un
peu sadiques john frankenheimer il m'a
dit le dernier jour ce moment là veulent
m'a dit bon tu peux aller tu peux aller
à paris
et puis la grosse déception parce que
bob dylan n'était pas au meilleur de sa
forme et vraiment c'est le moins qu'on
puisse dire
et il a déçu les attentes du public car
c'était pas c'était pas très bon la
manière dont il a chanté dont il a joué
de la guitare et c est donc à l'entracte
il ne revenait pas puisqu'il faisait les
deux parties est quelqu'un est venu me
demander d'aller dans sa loge
alors ce que sinon il ne remontait pas
sûr voilà je me souviens absolument pas
de ce qui a pu se passer dans sa loge
moi j'étais terrifiée je fais une espèce
de vampires jaune avec avec des ongles
trop l'ama c'était une gaufre est alors
que je pense moi je ne vous raconte pas
c'est qu'ensuite vous allez tous
savaient que zouzou johnny hallyday
hugues aufray et vous au genre g5 bob
dylan is not complètement le johnny
hallyday zouzou et aï beaufai il vous
prend vous dansez dans sa suite et
voyages il me prouve toute façon sa
suite royale et il vous fait écouter
just like a woman he wants you ce sont
quand même des plus grandes chansons
vous l'avez vous l'avez revu après non
non non mais c'est pas sinon je suis et
je sais j'ai su que récemment quand il
était à paris peut-être pas la dernière
fois mais l'avant dernière fois alors
grandement de il avait déjà menacé ni
maintenant je me sens enfin bon je sais
qu'il a demandé de mes nouvelles
allez je préfère qu'il reste avec le
fantasme de la photo de mes 20 ans
plutôt que me voir pour voir la ruine
que je suis devenu sourd quand je vais
pas de la saisir comme ça arrêtez vous
un essai